About 1,600 years ago,
St. Augustine wrote "The Confessions,"
which was the story
of his youthful descent into sin
and his later conversion to Christianity.
And book two of “The Confessions”
has a great beginning:
"I propose now to set down
my past wickedness
and a carnal corruption of my soul."
So you expect sex.
(Laughter)
But to the disappointment
of readers over the centuries,
the sin that Augustine talks about...
isn’t carnal at all.
It has to do with pears.
He and his friends break into an orchard
and they steal some pears.
And that was it.
They didn’t have anything against
the person who owned the orchard.
They weren’t hungry;
they threw the pears to pigs.
What stunned Augustine and disturbed him
was that he seemed to be motivated
by a desire just to do wrong.
He writes, "If any part of one
of those pears passed my lips,
it was the sin that gave it flavor.
I had no motivation for wickedness
except wickedness itself.
I was foul and I loved it."
(Laughter)
Now I'm a psychologist
and I was interested in real-life
stories of perverse actions,
so I started The Perversity Project
where I invited people to send me stories
about perverse things that they did.
I defined these acts as
"when you choose to do something
you know is wrong,
morally or otherwise,
at least, in part, because it's wrong."
So one of the first stories I got was,
"Flirted with a woman's boyfriend
knowing fully well he liked me.
I knew I could steal him if I wanted,
but I didn't want to do that.
I just wanted her to feel uncomfortable
whenever the three of us
were in the same room."
(Laughter)
"Causing people pain is wrong,
but that's exactly why I did it."
And in fact, this is the plot
of the Dolly Parton song "Jolene."
(Laughter)
Sometimes it's self destructive.
A young man wrote to me,
"Ice skating on a pond,
dark unfrozen spot 30 yards out,
instead of avoiding it,
I skate towards it,
knowing but wondering,
knowing but wondering...
and splash!"
(Laughter)
Now psychologists
have long been interested
in these sort of violent,
disruptive, perverse acts
and the kinds of people who do them.
An example people often give
is the Joker from the “Batman” comics.
In Christopher Nolan's film
"The Dark Knight,"
Alfred, Batman’s butler,
describes the Joker by saying,
"Some men can't be bought, bullied,
reasoned or negotiated with.
Some men just want
to watch the world burn."
And psychologists have thought up
a "need for chaos" scale
that gives you a bunch of statements
and how much you agree with them
will tell you how much
you want to watch the world burn.
So do this quietly in your head.
"I need chaos around me.
It's too boring if nothing is going on."
"Sometimes I just like
destroying beautiful things."
But not all the stories I got
had that kind of nature.
Some were a little bit more benign.
Here's one of my favorites.
"On one occasion in my early 20s,
I was out with a friend.
He decided to get himself an ice cream
and before he had a chance to try it,
I stuck my finger in it."
(Laughter)
"I tried to play it off as a joke,
but really I had the sudden thought,
’Man, it would be -- messed up
if I just jammed my finger
in his ice cream.'"
Someone else wrote me,
"When I was in a professional choir,
at every concert,
I felt the desire to sing a few notes
very incorrectly on purpose.
To this day, I don't
completely understand why."
Someone else wrote me,
and this is kind of the sweetest, saddest
little example of modest perversity:
“Sometimes I walk on the grass
instead of the path
just because I know it's wrong."
(Laughter)
Now a lot of perversity
makes the world worse.
I wouldn't want an Uber driver
who scores high
on a "need for chaos" scale.
And I don't want a friend
or a colleague either.
But sometimes, I'll suggest to you,
perversity can be clever,
creative, beautiful.
And there are some examples from art.
There was an illustrious art exhibition
in New York City in 1917, and they said,
"You could send in anything you want,
we'll accept everything."
So Marcel Duchamp sent in a urinal,
described [as] a fountain,
and they rejected it.
They said, "No, no,
we just accept artwork."
But Duchamp insisted it was artwork
and the resulting controversy turned out
to be one of the pivotal moments
in the history of modern art.
Or take Banksy.
A few years ago,
Banksy sold a painting “Girl with Balloon”
at Sotheby’s, at auction,
and he set up the frame so
that the moment the painting was sold,
the moment the gavel went "boom,"
a machine in the frame shredded
the painting halfway through,
horrifying the audience.
But... getting on the front pages
of newspapers all over the world.
Later on, describing it, Banksy quotes
a Russian anarchist who says,
"The urge to destroy
is also a creative urge."
Or take comedy.
Perversity is part and parcel of comedy.
So much of what's funny
is when people do things
that are irrational or immoral.
In the right hands, perversity
is such a source of joy.
Perversity can also be powerful.
Rory Sutherland wrote,
"Irrational people are much more powerful
than rational people."
He gave two reasons why this is so.
The first is, their threats
are so much more convincing.
Suppose I'm in a confrontation with you
and you threaten me
and you’re a rational,
reasonable... person.
So I know your threats ...
Woman: Ehh.
(Laughter)
PB: Well, I know your threats are going
to be normal, proportional and reasonable.
But, if as somebody is hinting here,
you’re a perverse agent,
I have no idea what you're capable of
and you're far more frightening to me.
Second reason is,
if you're wholly predictable,
people learn to hack you.
So again, if you're rational
and I have to outsmart you,
figure out what you're going to do next,
I figure you’ll do the rational thing.
If you're perverse,
you're harder to predict.
And so harder to hack.
Edgar Allan Poe, describing perversity,
described, talked about imps,
little magical demons in our heads
that cause us to do terrible things.
But like I said, I'm a psychologist,
I don't believe in imps.
I think what we do has reasons,
has motivations.
And I think for perverse actions
there is a range of them.
One of them was mentioned by Augustine.
So later on, after describing the incident
with the pears, he writes,
"I would not have done it by myself.
My satisfaction did not lie in the pears,
it lay in the crime itself,
committed in league
with a gang of sinners."
The social force drove him.
And there are other things, too.
One force that really interests me
goes under many names:
self-governance, freedom,
liberty, agency.
Call it autonomy.
Call it a desire to be free
to do what you want,
free of the constraints of other people
and free also of the constraints
of rationality and morality.
And Jonah Berger gives
a nice example of this.
He talks about the Tide Pod challenge
of a few years ago,
where many teenagers,
instead of using these
as detergent products,
bit into them and sometimes consumed them.
Now, as you might imagine,
Procter and Gamble,
who own the products,
were incredibly unhappy about this
and they set up an extremely
expensive ad campaign
designed to stop people
from consuming these products.
And one of their campaigns
involved a ... popular football player
known as Gronk.
So the ad would begin,
"Hey, Gronk, is eating the pods
ever a good idea?"
And Gronk responds, "No, no, no."
Berger points out, when this ad came up,
consumption of the pots shot up.
(Laughter)
Not down.
"Nobody's going to tell me what to do.
Who is this Gronk telling me what to do?
I want to be an autonomous, free being."
And psychologists call this reactance.
This means it's "an unpleasant feeling
that emerges when people
experience a threat to
or loss of their free behaviors."
And there's a wealth of laboratory
studies looking at reactance.
So they test the idea
that what you try to do is reestablish
the threatened freedom.
And so one of the studies, for instance,
looks at binge-drinking ads
and finds that when binge drinking ads
are particularly heavy-handed,
people often respond by drinking more. ...
"I'm going to reestablish my freedom."
"I'm going to do what I want."
Or take threats of reprisal.
There's a lovely study
by a team of political scientists
which asked you, asked the subjects,
to imagine that they’re
an ambassador to a country
and they're deciding whether or not
to have sanctions
towards that country.
In one condition, the dictator says
"If you do sanctions towards our country,
that's OK, I won't do anything."
In the second condition,
the dictator says,
"If you do sanctions towards our country,
I will unleash terrorist
attacks against you."
What's the stunning finding from this
is that in the second condition,
not the first,
they were more likely to do it.
A lot of our perverse actions
are in response to people
telling us not to do what we want to do,
and it makes us want
all the more to do that thing.
I think there are two lessons
from the study of perversity.
One is to appreciate
its role in everyday life.
It's really worth knowing
that there are people out there
who really do want
to watch the world burn.
And I think it's also worth knowing
that each and every one of us,
at some point in our life,
wants to watch the world burn
at least a little bit.
(Laughter)
I think it's worth knowing,
at least for consequential decisions
like choosing who to vote for,
that people aren't just motivated
by material self-interest
or by an affiliation
to social and political group.
Sometimes people want
to be autonomous beings,
they want to be free.
And telling these people,
"What you're doing is stupid,"
"what you're doing is irrational,"
"what you're doing is immoral,"
can have the paradoxical effect
of motivating them to do
exactly what you don't want them to do.
The second lesson of perversity
has to do with our everyday lives.
A lot of perversity is awful.
I think the world
would be better off without it.
But I think we've seen a little bit
that perversity could be funny.
It could be clever.
I think it can make
the world a better place.
And so I guess I'd suggest
that a life with a little bit
of perversity in it,
a life where sometimes you put your finger
into your friend's ice cream,
is a life that's a lot more interesting.
Thank you.
(Applause)